welcome to your weekend ticket first
we'll check out who came out on top and
last weekend's box office numbers then
we'll let you know what's new in
theaters this weekend and finally we'll
leave you with some new releases to
stream on Fandango now Sonic the
Hedgehog doesn't just gotta go fast it's
gotta break records the family-friendly
film had the largest debut weekend ever
for a video game adaptation coming in
with 58 million over the traditional
weekend to last year's best of 54
million from detective Pikachu
Sonic the Hedgehog totaled 70 million
over Presidents Day for Day weekend
making it the fourth highest Presidents
Day weekend of all time that's a lot of
rings speaking of breaking records last
weekend's other new wide release fantasy
island a pg-13 update of the classic TV
show with an edit bloom house horror
twist became the highest-grossing horror
film debut of this year so far at 14
million after Presidents Day and from
presidents to the current king of social
media bong Joon hos parasite walked away
with four Oscars the previous weekend
including becoming the first ever
foreign language film to win Best
Picture parasite also returned to 2,000
theaters added 6.8 million to its total
box office and had a 234 percent
increase in ticket sales this marks the
largest post Oscars boost for a Best
Picture winner in the past decade the
South Korean film entered the top ten
for the weekend and became the fourth
highest grossing foreign language film
of all time in the u.s. at 45 million
and pushed its total gross over 205
million worldwide
to live again who needs a friend the
first new movie hitting theaters this
weekend is a horror movie sequel called
Brahms the boy - this time around it's a
new story and a new cast but the same
director and the same old creepy
well-dressed doll when a family with a
troubled son moves into the guest house
of heelshire mansion from the first
movie it isn't long before they find
Brahms the son quickly becomes eerily
bonded to the doll who seems to have
upped his creepy abilities sorry Katie
Holmes
like I said director William Brent Bell
returns as does the writer of the first
movie Stacey meaner so if you like the
first movie you'll probably want to
catch this one the call of the wild also
comes out this weekend in this film
adaptation of the popular novel Harrison
Ford teams up with a hairy co-pilot once
again this time it's a tortured sled dog
named buck after buck is ripped from his
home sold as a sled dog and indoors
mistreatment he eventually meets John
Thornton and the two set off on
adventures in the wild testing their
strength and bond the novel is told from
bucks point of view and it looks like
the film is staying true to giving him a
lot of personality the CG buck is a scan
of a real-life dog adopted by the
director and his motion capture is acted
by human Terry notary who also did the
mocap for Kong and Kong Skull Island
also director Chris Sanders has writing
credits on several movies you're
probably familiar with like Aladdin
Mulan lilo and Stitch How to Train Your
Dragon and Beauty and the Beast just to
name a few
there's also some great movies that are
now available to stream at home on
Fandango now let's start with Oscar
winner
Jojo rabbit take out YTD won his first
Oscar for Best Adapted Screenplay with
this film about a young kid growing up
in Germany during World War two Jojo
rabbit is a satire that follows a lonely
German boy named Jojo played by Roman
Griffin Davis who idolizes Hitler and
Nazis but he finds that his loyalties
are tested when he learns his mother is
hiding a Jewish girl in his house the
film stars Scarlett Johansson newcomer
Roman Griffin Davis Sam Rockwell and
writer director Tycho YTD as Hitler as
of this filming the movie sits at an 80%
certified fresh' and an audience review
score of 95 percent cuz who doesn't love
Tycho ITT
no one no one doesn't like takeaway TV
now available to stream the
oscar-nominated beautiful day in the
neighborhood while not a biopic on the
life of the lovable Fred Rogers this
movie is based on a real-life story the
film tells the story of a reporter whose
life is touched by Mister Rogers as he
learns more about the man and his
positive impact on the world around him
Tom Hanks of course plays Fred Rogers
and was given blessing and praise from
mr. Rogers widow Joann Rogers for his
portrayal and if afterwards you want a
deeper biographical look into mr. Fred
Rogers heartwarming life
I recommend won't you be my neighbor
also available for digital purchase on
Fandango now there's so much mr. Rogers
that's your weekend ticket leave us a
comment below and let us know what
you'll be watching this weekend
I'm kil anonymous and I'll see you next
Tuesday with more box office numbers new
releases and new movies available to
stream at home on Fandango now
[Music]